So there's this wacky former judge.
She's a pro-Trump judge named Jeanine Pirro.
She does a weekend show on Fox News.
I don't I think it might just be a once a
week show, but maybe it's like a Friday, a
Saturday and Sunday show.
But I believe it's just once a week.
She appeared extremely impaired and disheveled
during her program over the weekend.
And the speculation that's running rampant
is that she seemed to be very, very drunk.
First, her show was delayed for technical
difficulties.
Now, presumably, that's something related
to some.
Thing about her socially distanced studio,
it was really a technical issue.
But when the show started, Judge Jeanine was
slurring her words.
She looked visibly disheveled.
At one point, she appeared to be nodding off
while her guest was speaking.
And the idea now is, is it possible that Judge
Jeanine was actually drunk?
Now, whether or not her drunkenness explains
the technical delay of the show, we just have
no idea.
Let's go to the first clip.
She seems confused about what the next segment
is.
And as you can hear right before, it's so
crazy, right before the intro graphic cuts
to her, you actually hear her yell to someone
off camera somewhere.
I can't before she starts confusedly reading
the teleprompter.
Take a look at this.
All right.
Wait.
Joining us.
Every time that they came back from a commercial
break, she seemed more impaired.
Check this out.
And here is a very labored teleprompter reading
from Judge Jeanine.
Welcome back to Justice.
Just the other day, the president talked or
was hoping about the possibility of reopening
everything on Easter Sunday.
And in a way where we can kind of come out
of this quarantine as loose as it may be that
we're involved in.
And Lisa Booth, the Fox News contributor,
is here to talk with us tonight about whether
that's even a possibility.
How are you, Lisa?
So alcohol is the main thing that's being
mentioned.
Quaaludes was the other thing being thrown
around, sort of a throwback to the Wolf of
Wall Street era.
At another point, she appears to be sort of
nodding off while her guest talks her head,
kind of leaning more and more to her left
until she seems to kind of be startled back
into a higher level of coherence.
So it's very weird.
And anyway, who knows what this exactly is,
but it keeps happening.
Remember that Rudy Giuliani's evening appearances
on Fox News and other TV stations were limited.
They tried to get Rudy on during the day because
his evening drinking at dinner was becoming
a problem.
And he would then go on TV after having had
a few too many, along with one of those big
cigars that he likes last week.
Maybe it was the week before.
It's all blending together.
We saw Trump economic adviser Larry Kudlow,
who is known to have previously had pretty
severe drinking problems.
He seemed impaired on television.
And now Judge Jeanine Pirro, things are all
just crazy.
In the era of coro air era of Corona virus.
And again, I want to be really clear.
Alcoholism is nothing to laugh at.
And in fact, I think we need to be taking
extra care during this time.
To mention a lot of people are under stress,
anxiety, depression, cabin fever, erratic
behavior, because these are not normal times.
I've never experienced anything like this
in my lifetime.
Most people alive today have never experienced
a sort of shut down.
Quarantine isolation situation like this at
the global scale in in any of their lifetimes.
And I understand turning to whatever it is.
Right.
We're we're hearing about people turning to
benzos.
We're hearing about people turning to alcohol,
etc.
But whatever it is that's going on at Fox
News with the drinking and the impaired ness
and and right wingers who seem to be impaired
on TV, it's getting a little bit weird and
it's more than just concerning.
Let me know what you make
of
the Jeanine Pirro thing.